oh my god I knew it it's really just the
hair you're still a teenager what is the
main source of your angst and how do you
get over those moments oh my god I don't
know what I would have done honestly if
it weren't for this movie because I
really got to like let it all out I had
moments I feel like I was close to fully
going Nadine 19 year old Hailee
Steinfeld is Nadine in the coming-of-age
story about a high school junior
navigating that teen end-of-the-world
drama
Nick I like you and I just want to be
with you we can do it in the petland
stockroom now when was the last time you
had an epic I've sent like a text to the
wrong person was it about them no your
meaning no someone else said to them I
know thank God yeah so dramatic
okay hey life isn't fair sometimes
Nadine okay get over then there's the
best friend hooking up with Nadine's
all-star irritatingly perfect older
brother and kyra sedgwick is her
predictable mom I'm not playing your
little games Nadine congratulations you
have all the answers don't you
and her tough love teacher turned
confidant is woody harrelson you having
a problem today maybe several I don't
really have any friends at the moment
Nadine she doesn't have a lot of friends
but you Haley have the squad we have
just the craziest schedules so it's it's
really fun when we do find that we're
all in the same place at the same time
that we get together Haley's got Taylor
on the squad a new movie and a new album
in the works
I was starving tonight taste is you
you're like a new JLo okay shooting from
acting - singing - sing it acting like
so fast